-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
and, now,
if you don't mind, we are going
to get to the news.
President Biden signed the
bipartisan infrastructure bill
into law yesterday and said,
"America is moving again.
And, this time, not to Canada."
[ Laughter ]
During the signing
ceremony yesterday
for the bipartisan
infrastructure bill,
President Biden twice referred
to Arizona
Senator Kyrsten Sinema
as Krysten, and that's the worst
thing you can call her,
besides a Democrat.
She hates that.
[ Ohs and laughter ]
According to a new book,
former acting Defense Secretary
Christopher Miller
purposely offered
then-President Trump
extreme military scenarios
in the final weeks
of his presidency,
to prevent him
from choosing to attack Iran.
Unfortunately, he opted
for the craziest one --
attacking the U.S.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
I guess that's about as well
as that one could've gone.
[ Laughter ]
"You guys remember
that awful day.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
[ Laughter ]
Ha ha ha ha ha."
Former Trump advisor
Steve Bannon surrendered
to federal authorities yesterday
to face charges
of contempt of Congress and,
looking at him,
I have to assume Congress is
a brand of soap?
[ Laughter and applause ]
The Biden administration
has announced it's planning
to hold the annual White House
Christmas party this year,
but, for the first time
in four years,
without Frosty.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
After being treated
for the coronavirus
at Walter Reed Medical Center
last year,
former President Trump
reportedly considered
ripping off his dress shirt
when he returned
to the White House,
to reveal a Superman shirt
underneath.
But then, he remembered
Superman was
an "undocamented inmigrant."
[ Laughter and oohs ]
Definitely said
both those words wrong.
[ Laughter ]
It is "undocamented," right?
What happened was the wheels
came off on undocumented
and then, I was lost
on immigrant.
[ Laughter ]
I think I used one of the M's
in immigrant
in undocumented,
so, there's only one left there.
[ Laughter ]
Guardrails came off, bud.
You know what?
Just, in post,
move the "M."
[ Laughter ]
Audio, if you're listening,
just take the "M"
from "undocumamented"...
[ Laughter ]
...slide it into immigrant
and I think it'll be seamless.
[ Laughter ]
They'll match it to my lips,
so, I'll just say it right now
without words
and then,
you can use these lips.
[ Laughter ]
Just watch the show tonight
and see, yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Let's see how they
cut it together.
A woman reportedly climbed
over the barrier
to Bronx Zoo's lion exhibit
last week
while carrying a bouquet
of roses,
or, as the lion saw it,
dinner, holding some garnish.
[ Laughter and awws ]
More than 450 people in Egypt
were stung over the weekend
after flooding drove thousands
of scorpions into villages.
And that's why you don't tap
on the glass
of King Tut's mummy!
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally --
[ Laughter ]
Is it a good sign or a bad sign
when I can only hear
Wally laughing?
[ Laughter ]
And fi--
I think you're laughing
because nobody else was, Wally,
and I don't like that.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, keep it up, Wally.
And, finally,
the restaurant chain Applebee's
began offering so-called
Cosmic Wings yesterday,
which features chicken tossed
in Original or Flamin' Hot
Cheetos cheese sauce,
and that's not all
they're tossed in.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That was a monologue, everybody.